so initially I had every intention of
uploading the death of Deadpool today
but then I started thinking that I
remembered Benny and I had this sort of
deal going on the sort of challenge
going on about Deadpool worried about
daredevil videos we were gonna upload
daredevil videos for the rest of the
week until Friday and then of course get
into the death of Deadpool probably next
week and so I started doing a search and
I was like I wonder if there were any
stories we're dead oh dear double
crossover with any of the characters
from DC Comics and then I found a
daredevil Batman crossover and I said no
way there's no way this actually
happened and I started looking into it I
was like I have to do this video so
without further ado this is the first
Batman in daredevil crossover to ever
take place and it came out in 1997 this
is called Batman daredevil and it's
called I 4 and I now the way this story
picks up Batman simply just arrives in
New York City and the reason why is
because he's been tracking two-face he's
been looking for - face to face had
basically been engaging in a series of
heists in Gotham City and one of which
was basically him stealing something
called a neural net processor now the
neural net processor is basically a
device that will allow or I guess is
modeled after the human brain and it's
designed to be a computer chip the
functions like a human brain although at
the moment we don't know exactly what it
is I guess the two-face wants with this
thing so what happens is that once
Batman actually arrives in in New York
he immediately takes to the sewers to
basically try to find what is this going
on where it is two-face is going because
he knows a two-face really isn't gonna
travel along the normal streets he's
gonna go underground and as he's
travelling along this route he
ultimately finds daredevil now daredevil
at this time is tracking down mr. Hyde
now they don't know that two-face and
mr. Hyde are working together at this
moment they simply are just tracking
people of their for their own personal
reasons but once daredevil realizes
Batman is there by virtue of his his
extra sensors his extra sensory input
the two of them begin to fight now the
fight is actually a pretty cool scene
whereby they're both able to counter the
other's moves of course Batman throws
his batarangs at daredevil and daredevil
catches them which i think is probably
one of the coolest moments and this
whole thing where daredevil just simply
snatches them out of the air before they
actually hit him in addition we see the
two of them just kind of going through
hand-to-hand but ultimately they both
sort of agree here
that if they're tracking people who may
very well be working together then their
goal should be to basically track these
individuals down proper to go after them
to figure out what their plan is in the
ended as opposed to fighting each other
and so what they do is they effectively
team up now what happens is once they go
on the prowl and they begin looking for
their respective members for twoface and
for mr. Hyde with a Batman and daredevil
proper they come across what appears to
be one of their most recent heists now
one of the most recent highs seems to be
at a at a jewelry store and this seems
sort of weird because what seems to be
happening is that two-face and mr. Hyde
are just going about committing crimes
or just kind of going on this criminal
spree there doesn't really seem to be a
rhyme or reason for why they're doing it
and so what happens is they come across
a woman named Wendy Moreau and Wendy
Moreau has basically been killed now as
far as I understand it
Wendy Moreau is not a character that has
any significance although I might be
wrong here in the fact that she might be
a minor character but as far as I
remember she doesn't really have
anything major due in Marvel I think she
just may very well be a person who was
just in the wrong place at the wrong
time when this heist was committed but
she's been killed and so they take her
body down and as Batman says they're
basically going to give her her dignity
back to basically bury her properly but
the two of them continue investigating
here now ultimately what happens is that
daredevil begins to piece the pieces
together alongside Batman and what they
realize is that if two phases has stolen
a neural net processor that's designed
to tap into the human brain
then from Daredevils calculations mr.
Hyde is probably in some capacity
consumed this neural net processor now I
wouldn't say consumed in the sense that
he's literally swallowed it that in some
way the neural net processor is tied in
to his physiology and that whenever it
is that a mr. high commits crimes
whenever it is that he begins to amp up
and use his physical strength that it
pumps the I guess this the juices so to
speak where it pumps these pheromones
into the the chip proper and it enhances
the chip and so what would happen is
that two-face would then be able to take
this chip and sell it to somebody else
for far more than it's worth because it
would be a more enhanced version of its
normal neural net processing self but
the problem is that mr. Hyde would not
survive the ordeal mr. high would end up
being killed and so this basically seems
to be a ruse by two-face whereby he's
using mr. Hyde to enhance the chip and
the mr. Hyde will die so that suface can
turn around and
sell the chip and so what happens is
Batman and daredevil after realizing
this continue their efforts and
ultimately track down mr. Hyde and
two-face now when they track them down
they're in the midst of a heist and
Batman is the first one to arrive there
and of course mr. Hyde not knowing who
Batman is basically continues so I guess
goes into the position of fighting
Batman and two-face continues to fight
Batman as well now daredevil joins the
fray a few minutes after and so you
basically have this big conflict between
two-face daredevil Batman and mr. Hyde
all of which are trying to figure out
what in the world's going on here now
ultimately we find that daredevil begins
to prey on the nature of to face and the
since the two-face needs balance he
needs order there has to be a coin for
him to flip and in order for him to
decide what the outcome needs to be but
the coin seems to have been taken away
by daredevil or the very least it's not
in two phases immediate area where you
can grab it and so what happens as
daredevil begins to prey on a prey on
this and simply saying that two-face
himself needs to make a decision that he
has to reach back to Harvey Dent and
what Harvey's instead for to decide what
needs to happen with heaven when mr.
Hyde and so ultimately what two-face
seems to do is he takes a syringe which
is designed to neutralize the neural net
processor chip he calculates the syringe
accordingly and then stabs mr. Hyde in
the neck with it now we're not really
told why it is that two-face had
basically backed out of the deal with
with mr. Hyde but it seems as though
once mr. Hyde was told what it is a two
phases plan was that he was going to
kill two-face and so two-face was
basically faced with the idea of either
losing his life or bringing an end to
mister Hyde which of course he decided
to bring it into mr. Hyde and so what
this does is this brings an end to the
conflict with regards to Batman in
daredevil and mr. Hyde and two-face and
so what we'll find depending on whether
or not you guys like this video we may
do the second one we may do the the
crossover they came in 2000 when Batman
and and and daredevil crossed over yet a
second time in Gotham City itself as
opposed to New York with that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys
be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates for
comics explained and talk to me directly